all right i'm going to get started this
is lecture 19 of 1413 uh i'm gonna first
finish up um
uh some of what we discussed last time
on uh gender
discrimination and identity and then
then we're gonna
talk about uh nudges and uh default
effects
um so uh let me sort of fairly quickly
go through the remaining slides of
lecture 18 and then move to the
lecture slides so remember we talked
last time about
the study by betron did all about gender
identity norms
where we talked about uh because um so
the authors argue there's this norm that
some men perceive perhaps even
some women that men should be earning
more than their wives
there's this clip this missing mass of
households
or couples in the us we talked about um
different reasons for that uh missing
couples did not form in the first place
that such
marriage is a couple service uh happy
and stable
um so like they end up in divorce um and
you know there's also
uh even for existing couples that form
whether the wife uh
the woman has more earnings potential um
uh in some cases at least um uh women
tend to either sort of work less a few
hours
and therefore perhaps could less promote
it and the like and in addition i might
be
uh involved in more non-market and child
care
work which you should have called the
second shift they have to do more work
um because you know the husband is very
unhappy about her anymore
which then of course uh holds
potentially um
uh uh the wife back at at her work
now uh somebody was asking last time i i
believe justin about or
others about um the arrival of children
and the gender gap
um this system so there's quite a few
studies like this one so i added this
here which is the study by clavin at all
in denmark
and uh these studies essentially show
there's like a substantial
um what they call child penalty for
for women which is when you look at uh
men's and women's earnings on the left
hand side um there's a figure shows
earnings this is sort of yearly data
over time
on the right hand side um you see hours
work similarly you
see productivity but essentially you
tend to see is that for men and this is
sort of the gray bar here on top
um you know you see essentially before
the child is born you sort of match
mental women um to have sort of similar
earnings the trajectory looked very
similar
and and then from then perhaps you know
there's a slight decline or no
like for the increase over time um but
for for for women there's like a clear
drop in
earnings and that drop persists for many
many years so it's not just like there's
a year after birth you know there's
lower earnings for
on average for women but there's a
persistent gap overall
that has to be presumably with like some
women never returning back to
to work some women remaining part-time
just some women working a few hours when
they have children
notice that that's not just about like
hours works so when you look at the
earnings
gap it's about something like 20 percent
the long-run child penalty here is
like 20 uh it's also for hours worth of
something like 10
which must mean that like the there's an
additional 10 percent coming from like
productivity or wages conditional on
hours work so it's not only that women
are
working few hours but they're also paid
less per hour which presumably is like
once
um people start quite working a few
hours
take more breaks or just take a break
for a few years they're becoming
uh they're getting less promotions and
so on and that sort of carries through
for a long time
now interestingly some of these child
penalties are transmitted through
generations meaning that from parents to
daughters
sort of suggesting essentially in the
same family where there's um
child penalties from the parents like i
said like if the woman
uh the is a child penalty for uh
the mother um the daughter will also be
likely to have a child penetrate penalty
later on like 20 30 years when she's
been actually working so there seems to
be something to do with like the child
uh environment and sort of gender
identity which is sort of the norm that
the woman is supposed to take care of
the children um versus the husband is
not
and that seems to be sort of uh
permeated to generations
um in the child environment um
now you might sort of say well then
couldn't we just do some policies that
um support women or support parents to
sort of help them deal with children um
uh better and you know wouldn't that um
help and there are some policies that
people have done in particular in
academia you might
say well if a woman has a child or a
couple as a child in general
um you know that's that's surely a hint
to
uh uh productivity and so therefore you
know one could sort of say well that's
where that's in fact what people have
been doing is sort of let's
stop 10-year clock which essentially is
you know as an assistant professor
people have something like seven eight
nine years
uh to do research until tenure she might
say let's give people another year
um if they have a child now one proposal
is to have gender neutral um
clock-stopping policies now these
policies are intended to involve these
gender-neutral policies meaning that
like both
parents regardless of um who's
giving or you know not just the person
who's giving birth but also the other
person who's taking care of the child
potentially
is getting an additional um a year on
the tenure clock
so the intention is here in particular
to involve men more in in child care
but you know um those kinds of policies
tend to be not enforced and
potentially they might even enhance
gender inequality
if it's the case that like both men and
women get another year
but the man essentially takes that as a
year off where you can do
um additional work while the woman is
back taking care of
of the household and the child then such
policies in some ways
might make things worse and this is
exactly what some studies find
that these gender mutual policies in
particular sort of
in economics that's also some examples
from other settings
uh but essentially uh uh introducing
such policies substantially uh reduce
female attendant rates while increasing
male tenure rates
so here's a policy that looks actually a
good policy it's gender-neutral and so
on um but in fact it might not be
depending on who takes advantage of that
and doesn't
so it's a very tricky question because
you know um some of these things are not
um enforceable
if instead you gave only um these
10-year extensions to women then you
could get issues like in
households that then like women are sort
of pushed out of work um which in part i
think some of these
neutral tenure clocks try to avoid in
the first place so it's not unclear what
to do here but i think
it's important to understand that some
policies that look uh like they
are uh in fact mutual or gender neutral
they might in fact
um not be now let me tell you
uh uh uh about one more people related
to gender and the labor market or
identity
which is a very nice people by [ __ ]
um
which asks the question when women avoid
um
career enhancing actions because these
actions signal undesirable
traits so in particular women might be
or ambitious women might be perceived as
not attractive partners
um in the labor market among some
in particular in some settings uh such
as among mba students
um and so in particular um as you as you
might be familiar with
um there's lots of dating happening or
among
mba students where people try to
essentially find um
partners are somebody to get married to
and
um it appears to be the case that being
ambitious who being
perhaps overly ambitious is perceived as
uh negatively and as an undesirable
trait uh on the
dating market for mbas now what we're
seeing and i'll find and this is
um a joint work with um amanda palais
and
um uh toomas for jivara um they find
that married and unmarried female mba
students perform similarly um when their
performance is unobserved by classes so
these are things like exams
problem sets these are things that only
the professor sees but not necessarily
their classmates
so here male and sorry unmarried and
married
female mba students do similarly well
when comparing them
but unmarried women have lower
participation grades so these are
essentially things that you know what
do you say something in class and as you
might know in mba classes
in some at least there's somebody
sitting in the back actually recording
each interaction each participation
um very sort of carefully so you know
exactly who says
uh how many things um and how often
and so on so it seems to me that like uh
unmarried women tend to not want
to look too ambitious and too hard
working in class
now that's of course only suggestive um
so then they also have a field
experiment
um where they ask people about their
desired salaries and willingness to
travel and work long hours
in a real estate's placement
questionnaire so this is essentially at
the end there's like these placement
or these career fairs but people ask
kind of about
these questions about like what salary
are you expecting are you willing to
travel really far
are you willing to work long hours and
so on and of course these questions
would have all signal
um ambition and then the really um
interesting part in the experiment is
then they vary whether this information
is perceived to be
private so you're just saying it's like
a recruiter but nobody else in your
class or anybody else might find out
versus whether there's some expectation
of some of their classmates
actually learning about your preferences
and what they find then is that the
single um
female students report lower on desire
salaries and willingness to travel and
work hours and work long hours
when they think that there's an
expectation that their classmates might
find out
about it which essentially is to say
they perceive it to be costly
for their class or if their classmates
find out about their ambition
now importantly two other things are
also true one is for other
groups so other women that are not
single or
for men essentially these responses are
unaffected by pure observability
observability
and second it seems to be that what's
driving the observer
observability result is the
observability by
single male peers so when other female
students or other
non-single male peers are potentially
seeing these
answers there's no effect but the effect
is really coming from
other single male peers potentially
seeing it which is precisely what you
expect
if you think you know having ambition is
a potentially a negative signal on the
um uh on the dating market so that's
another sort of uh
study showing that what these norms or
perceived norms
um are really important not just in
terms of like punishing women
in in some ways um uh uh
you know undeservably for like mistakes
as we saw in heather sorenson's paper
but also um uh by holding women back
by themselves right here here these are
single women who are highly qualified
um mba students who are
deliberately not as ambitious and
hardworking as perhaps you might
think they would like to be which is
sort of what the private responses
suggest
um because there's a penalty coming uh
waiting for them or perceived penalty
coming on
on the dating market any questions about
this
so here's a question about um uh can it
be the opposite um by the way i
better ask this um in person it's a
little bit hard for me to follow the
chat
but can it be that more confident women
tend to be married
uh yes in principle yes but i think in
what you see here in the experiment is
like
uh so notice that what i was saying i'm
just careful to say
um these are about there's a perceived
penalty of being overly ambitious
there may well be like for some women um
being very ambitious and so on that's a
very highly desirable trait
um but it seems to be that the
perception at least is that
um being highly ambitious and so on is
is is is not
is not uh desired
so i think there's another question by
lucy about like um
married women compensating for
discrimination i think that's all
um there might be other stuff going on
but i think the key part here is
the variation between private and public
among
um uh single female students so when
they are asking in private
they are saying essentially they want
higher salaries when they're asking in
public or
higher salaries and they're willing to
work long hours and so on when they're
answering in public they're essentially
holding back um
which seems to suggest and that's
consistent i guess also with the
participation grades um that's
consistent with like
there is at least a perception of a
lower desirability in particular among
their single male peers which is what
this results is driven by
right that's not to say it's not clear
by the way that the study shows that
that's actually true
that's about like these women's
perceptions it's also this study also
doesn't necessarily show that this
translates at the end of the day in
lower earnings and so on and so forth
the authors argue that that's the case
but you know
um these are only like sort of questions
real estates questions
and placement questionnaires it's just
sort of essentially more like a proof of
concept arguing that
this is an important force that might be
at play that women hold themselves back
in some ways here and and in the case of
like a placement
questionnaire
okay so let me um i had started this
already last time let me briefly
go through the westerland restaurant
study which essentially is saying that
uh there's sort of two forces going on
um uh they sort of demand
high uh uh in terms of like um
uh tasks that women and men are perhaps
asked differently
and beliefs could be quite important
here and mediating
who has to do which tasks and when so
let me show you a little bit what that
study is about
so the study is essentially asking the
question uh whether women are not saying
no often enough
on uh when it comes to work um
and it's sort of motivated by the fact
that female faculty members tend to do
a lot more what they call non-promote
multiple tasks these are tasks that
essentially everybody wants to do
somebody to do the task but they don't
want to do the tasks themselves so
that's like essentially university
committees and like
um here also undergraduate teaching
uh um our undergraduate student that
advising of course everybody loves
undergrads and wants to advise them
however it's not something that's good
for people's
career at the end of the day faculty are
often evaluated by research output
so any time that's spent on uh
committees etc
is sort of not going to be helping for
promotions eventually and
then one first observation is that women
do that much more on
them now you might sort of ask
why is that women spend their time
differently there's potentially issues
of demand women are just
asked a lot more to do these things and
there's potentially supply issues
conditional
being asked women might be just much
more likely to say yes
and now what this paper argues is that
demand and supply interact
because women are more likely to say yes
they're also more likely to be asked in
the first place
um okay so um why do we care i think i
already mentioned this this with a free
broad perspective
one is about we kind of try to
understand individual decision making
and sort of if you want to understand
how people make optimal decisions here's
sort of a reason why people prefer use
an example where people potentially
misoptimize
there's a managerial social planner
perspective that if you want to sort of
organize
um or if you want to organize
organizations to be efficient you want
to make sure that everybody does equal
uh work in some ways and you don't want
to be women who are
very productive be stuck in a bunch of
like um
um other tasks that hold them back
uh and then there's a public policy
perspective uh it might essentially be
that
um uh uh sex differences in the
allocation of times
women spending more time on these kinds
of tasks might explain whether
less likely to be promoted and so on
and sort of then understanding that and
understanding these issues might sort of
help with
interventions to improve equity now okay
so what are these tasks again there's
promotable tasks that's doing research
and there's non-promotable tasks so
promotable tasks meaning like
essentially if you do these tasks you're
likely to be promoted or
like essentially get tenure eventually
a non-promotable task essentially are
tasks that many people could do the
tasks
but you know everybody wants somebody to
do it but often nobody actually
wants to do it themselves now um the
authors are first like a field study
where they have on
faculty at a large public university
where you send essentially emails from a
chair
and they're requested to volunteer to
join one of several university-wide
faculty senate committees
and you know women are essentially on
[Music]
these tasks are way more likely to
volunteer conditional on being asked so
that's the first piece of evidence that
uh conditional one being asked women are
more likely to be asked
and you might say well that's perhaps
there's some personality firstly just on
maybe women are nicer maybe
women care more about the public good um
now what the authors show is that um
that might
be true in some cases but another case
and it's also about expectation about
who does it and who doesn't
um moreover uh the asks about like who
is ass is quite different depending on
whether you're male or female
and that's where the experiment comes in
so what they do in an experiment
is what's called the threshold public
good scheme it's very simple
which is um a small group um needs to
find a volunteer for a task
these are groups of three people and
there's like 10 rounds where people are
matched over time
with each other and so um it's
essentially set up to mimic real world
situations where everyone prefers the
past to be undertaken by someone
but not themselves okay yes you don't
want to do it you i'd like to have
somebody else to do it
you want that somebody does it but um
you just don't want to do it yourself
and so people get in the group of three
gets two minutes to decide whether to
invest when investing means essentially
you have to sort of press a button here
only one person can invest in the round
ends when someone
invests if no one invests all group
members get a dollar
if you are investing you get a dollar 25
and the remaining group members get two
dollars right so if you're thinking
about this task what you're thinking
about is now
hey is somebody else gonna invest and
um and b like conditional on your
beliefs about is somebody else going to
invest anytime soon
do you want to invest or or not clearly
it's the efficient
thing that somebody invests but you know
you don't want to be it yourself because
then you get only 125 rather than the
two dollars
and the clock ticks down until one
person invests so no investment is made
after two minutes okay so now what we
find
um or we define it as an experiment um
women are way more likely to invest
um in each of these rounds this is sort
of the red line here um this is the
uh blue line here is for men and so
women are much more likely uh to invest
in women that's very
uh demand that's very um clear when you
look at these figures
um uh and that's also very persistent
over time so it's not just like perhaps
in the first round and so on this is
even after 10 rounds when people
keep match being matched with others
over time women are much more likely to
invest now how do we interpret this so
how do we think about this what can we
learn about this so one
explanation that i already mentioned is
like women are much nicer
but can be unfurless from this task
you say if women are a lot nicer than
men well then you should find that like
we're more cooperative as lucy suggests
um if um women a lot more cooperative
you should see that in women-only groups
women are much more likely to invest
than in male only groups and that's
exactly um
what they try to do with the experiment
so they have essentially like
single uh sex sessions would have all
female
and all male groups and what you find is
well um the probability of investing is
actually exactly the same
for men or women they also find that
when trying to predict who's investing
and who's not
um any measures of social preferences
risk preferences and so on that they
have elicited previously
listed previously actually not
predictive of this behavior that sort of
suggests it's really not about
altruism in the sense of like being
nicer on more
wanting so in some sense investing is
doing something nice for the others in
your group
it doesn't seem to be that uh it's about
that
it's also not so much about like um risk
aversion so you might sort of say well
i'm investing because i
i really like certainty if i invest i
know exactly what i'm getting
if i'm not investing i get a chance of
like getting the two dollars or ten
essentially a lottery between two
dollars and one dollar depending on then
the probability is essentially your
belief about what you think is the
probability of others investing
so your risk aversion might matter but
they also show that risk aversion is
really not
important so now um they have
essentially two experiments
and one is the experiment one that i
showed you women are more likely to
invest in mixed sex
uh groups um and they have um women are
men are equally likely to invest in
single sex foods
and so now then what they're doing is
then they're trying to say well could it
be that beliefs that women will invest
are important here so that's essentially
the idea if you think that like you know
women are more likely to invest than men
if women think this and men
think this then essentially um you're
gonna get in a situation where
if you have a mixed um uh sex group then
you'll have one woman saying two men
the woman thinks like oh the men are not
gonna invest anyway so either it's like
for investing or getting a dollar
so then for the woman it's optimal to
invest and the men are going to think
well the woman is going to invest so
like why should they invest
if the woman is investing anyway for
them um it's then
um optimal um not to invest
now uh experiment three then gets at
this in some ways which essentially is
about
now um getting um women and men to
to ask to rest so what they do is
essentially to have a what's called the
phone or they call their photo ask which
they have um four people per group uh
three people as before can invest that's
essentially the same as before they call
them green players not sure why but
essentially these are green players
and one person is unable to invest but
um he can ask um one of the three others
to
to invest it's not a binding request
essentially just like it's
sort of a nudge if you want you can sort
of essentially suggest that and maybe
exert some social pressure
uh that's the red player and then the
red flag is essentially incentivized the
red player wants the
investment um to happen so this is kind
of what this looks like there's
essentially like three people that you
see as the red player and you can say
who would you ask
or many of these three that you see the
photos so obviously you see the gender
of
the person and so what they then find is
that women are much more likely
to be asked so you see here the red
lines are
more to the right or there's more red to
the right which is the total times
asked to invest so there's more mass to
the right for women
than for men now what did we learn from
that well
absent a request investment rates do not
differ by gender
but when asked to invest women are more
likely to do so
so there's two things going on here one
is when asked women are more responsive
and uh what should have said is that the
marginal increase of being asked is
higher for women
than for men and then in addition um
women are also more likely to be asked
which to say when people have the choice
about whom should you ask
well they kind of know who is the person
who is more likely to react which is
um um uh uh more likely is this
is the woman in the in the group so they
correctly
uh understand that if they ask the woman
that it's gonna have like
um more of an impact than asking men um
and that's true so when women ask
also more likely to comply
so now uh that essentially sort of says
these gender differences get amplified
by increase
for our women to contribute
so not only is it the case that um
they're more likely to say yes but on
top of that they also will get
more uh um requests which of course then
is like they do extra much work
overall so what's here is about this is
not about sort of preferences
it's essentially just an equilibrium
that at the end of the day
um uh will be sustained because again
like if men think women are going to do
it anyway and if women think
like well nobody's going to do it unless
i do it myself you end up sitting in
situations where it might be optimal for
both
women and men to do it conditional on
their beliefs
any questions on this study
okay so then um let me just uh
uh summarize a bit so we saw a large
gender wage in earnings gaps
um that even persisted even until now um
substantial progress has been made due
to the
technological advantage advances and
other improvements but
there's persistent gender differences uh
in many societies including the
us bias beliefs and identity concerns
uh appear to or play a particularly
important role
in particular since some issues such as
educational differences and so on
um and sort of
given the technological advances some of
these uh technological issues are less
important now
but really seems to be that biased
beliefs and identity concerns
uh are the center of explaining things
in addition to
the child penalty but even the child
penalty you might argue is driven by
beliefs and identity and so on and then
there are these feedback mechanisms
between demand and supplies of tasks or
like um
that women and men are doing and in
particular it seems to be that again
beliefs are important in the sense of
like it matters what people think other
people do
um
and what and that seems to create
essentially these uh inequalities across
gender now if you want to sort of
mitigate or reduce or eliminate the
gender gap it's really important
to understand these issues i think we
have made quite a bit of progress in
understanding what's going on and
identifying um the issue
now i think is the the next steps are to
try and understand what are policies
that are in fact um
successful in helping us do that so this
is a
this lecture is about default um not
json frames
and originally i plan to also do mental
accounting but um
given that we didn't finish last time i
should move this to a later lecture at
historic
okay so where are we in the course we
talked a lot about preferences we talked
a lot about beliefs and the interaction
of those and sort of potential
deviations from the
you know classical model now we're going
to talk about non-standard decision
making and one way to think about this
is to say
even if you understand people's
preferences very well and you can
understand these are non-standard
preferences in some ways and potentially
biased beliefs
even conditional on that people might
behave in some ways where they deviate
from the neoclassical model
that is hard to explain just by
deviations and preferences and beliefs
so there are additional deviations from
the neuroclassical model
that are beyond changes in preferences
and beliefs in particular
i'll talk now about frames um defaults
and not just mental accounting is a
similar case of that
we'll talk about this um later
okay and so the most famous paper in
this
in this space or one of the most famous
paperworks about 401k um
savings and so companies offer these for
1k savings
um that's right so it's a smack the most
common voluntary savings vehicle in the
us
what you do is you set aside some money
for retirement
and you choose the what's called the
contribution rate it's like what
fraction of the income what you
contribute
and you choose the um asset allocation
that is offered or that is offered by
companies by employers now why are
employers doing this
employers want to um it's seen as sort
of a nice thing that employers can do
for their um
for their employees um
it's potentially a way in which you can
create some form of solidarity with your
your employees in a way you want your
workers
to do well in retirement beyond they're
working for you and so on
um and then sort of um uh
overall what what companies often do is
they offer matching contributions up to
a threshold this often like incentivize
that
in fact fairly strongly um there's also
a penalty for early withdrawal why is
there a penalty for early withdrawal
yeah exactly it's like a you know soft
commitment device in some ways and a
sensible or it's
a hard commitment device in the sense of
like it's it's dominated um but
essentially it's like
you want it's sort of a mixture you
could have it like a hard commitment
a fully hard commitment or a very hard
moving device but you could say you
cannot
um withdraw this until like age you know
60 or something or 55 or whatever or 65
whenever you
retire that's not what it is instead
there's a penalty that's often like 10
percent
and the penalty is there because you
know you want to
get people avoid that people what's
called leakage
that people essentially would draw money
early uh presumably because of
self-control problems
present bias and so on there's lots of
leakage in fact even though there's a 10
uh withdrawal there's a 10 withdrawal as
opposed to like shutting it down
entirely because you know sometimes
people have shocks they have health
problems and so on they need a bunch of
money
and in those cases of course you want to
allow this or the company wants to allow
that to people so 10
penalty tends to be sort of a compromise
um between that
this tax deferral which is you pay
usually like a lower
uh marginal tax rate during retirement
right when people are 30 40 they earn a
lot of money
um compared to like when they're 70
during retirement
so people can pay taxes um uh when they
receive the money
at retirement so to the extent that your
marginal
tax rate is lower then um you're going
to save some money
from that so that's another reason why
you might want to to to use your 401k
savings
now uh what are some patterns of 401k
investments two-thirds of employees
believe that they're saving too little
when you just
ask them and one-fourth of these tends
to
uh intends to raise their savings in the
next two months so that's sort of the
typical thing that sort of smells like
self-control problems where you ask
people like
um uh uh are you happy with your savings
you'll be saving more or less and people
tend to say oh no i wanted to like
really save more
uh next two months i'm gonna do it this
is sort of the same as when you ask
people about the gym you know
um i always exercise more every month
but it happens almost nobody falls
and follows who in fact um the reported
under savers or
have low savings rates um you find
similar patterns also in other surveys
if you're interested in more of a toyota
survey survey does a very nice
job instead of summarizing these
patterns
now given these patterns what are
standard economics tools to increase
savings suppose you're the social
planner or a company on to increase
people's savings what would standard
economics 1401 for today or whatever
tell you
what should you do to to increase
people's savings
how would you do that first the matching
contribution is very much like an
incentive so like a very standard
straightforward
incentives econ 101 will tell you people
react to incentives so let's give
people incentives you provide matching
contributions and therefore people
essentially increases the rate of return
on savings
um and you know these matching
contributions i'll show you in a second
tend to be very high
but fairly high and so you know people
should be doing it more if you make it
more um
attractive at least under usual
circumstances
what else could we do
and maybe that's not necessarily um
standard economics of course one option
will be like the default
but what other options could be could we
do what else could we do
right so you could sort of so the
matching contribution is a way of doing
that essentially because i'm telling you
i'm i'm
matching however much you're uh
contributing by
adding so much money in your account and
you're not supposed to withdraw it so
that's implicitly giving you a
return another thing i think that you're
already saying is what i have here as
well which is
um provide additional choices for better
choices in some ways or improving what's
called or financial education that's to
say
maybe people are not investing in the
right thing and so maybe i could
need to give them like better investment
funds of other options that have higher
returns
and by doing so um you know people will
be inclined to save more
or maybe i can explain to them better
for example compound interest
and so on and sort of in sometimes maybe
people don't quite understand uh
perhaps because of low education and
that's not necessarily standard
economics in the sense of like people
are confused that's sort of not what
standard economics would say
but it might well be that people are uh
if you explain to them better
um uh you know what is compound interest
and if you save now like you know
five percent of your income how much
will that be in 30 years from now people
are often surprised because that's very
high
uh you could sort of get them provide
them with additional choices maybe make
it more attractive for them you could
even sort of subsidize it and say you
know here's a fund and i'm even giving
you more money
notice that that would be quite
expensive for the company to do over
time so
companies tend to not do that now it
turns out none of these tools tend to be
very effective so people have tried this
despite the fact that like they have
been
uh matching contributions despite you
know they've tried to like
do financial education sort of
information sessions
providing more choices and so on notice
that actually sometimes backfires
because people get confused because
there's too many choices so it's called
choice overload so these things tend to
not work particularly well
now one question again um
why are companies actually trying to
increase people's savings so in some
sense you might say well
we're offering here's your 401k savings
your offer
to you but whoever wants to wants to
actually do it
um i can use it and otherwise um we
really don't care that much
so why are companies still interested in
uh doing this why are people paying this
match
we had some answer already before but
that's actually not quite the answer of
where this is going
so it's tight because there's two
questions one question that we talked
about a little bit previously was like
why might the company offer savings
options anyway
and the second one is conditional and
offering that why is the company really
interested in increasing take
up because they say wow whatever like we
offer it some people
like it some people don't and if they
don't like it why do we care
um so i always thought you know when i
first read about this
um i thought you know companies are nice
and they want us to defeat good to their
employers and they want the best for
their workers
and you're already a lot more cynical um
in the sense of like
you're kind of saying well you know how
do we get workers to work a lot more
um it could be i mean i don't i haven't
heard of what you were saying but i
think in principle
um there could be a reason where in a
way i think
companies like workers should be happy
and to the extent that
uh if they consume more right now that
probably
makes them happier and perhaps more
productive so then in some ways probably
you have the incentives to have people
not save too much because in some ways
you don't care that much
about like whether when somebody is 60
uh
uh he's particularly happy with your
money because essentially you can't
really
uh engage your age discrimination is
illegal so you can't fire like a 57 year
old person
who's doing their job reasonably well
but maybe is not as productive as you'd
like them to be
and so then if you uh if that person has
saves a lot of money that probably are
more likely to to retire
you guys are more uh cynical um than i
am so
the um the uh reported reason for a lot
of these policies is in fact the reason
that there is irs non-discrimination
rules
what does that mean essentially
by the irs rules it cannot be that
people who are paid a lot
can benefit from certain retirement and
other schemes way more than people are
paid very little
now it turns out that like low income or
low wage workers
are much less likely to save
in 401k and other savings um
schemes therefore they're much less
likely to receive
any of these 401k matching and other
contributions
and therefore essentially their
companies tend to have way more
money spent on like sort of high paid
employees than low paid employees
and there's some non-discrimination
rules by the irs that says that's that's
that's
uh illegal you can't do that and
therefore
companies are very um keen on getting
lower
if you are like a ceo or something you
want your
workers to earn very low to invest in
401k
and other types of schemes that they get
rewarded for
because that allows them essentially to
pay the high paid
employees higher bonuses and sort of
these kinds of schemes um
as well so that's essentially one of the
reasons why companies are very very
interested
in increasing their 401k savings in
particular i'm more among workers
with low wages and that's exactly what
the um
defaults or default uh policies tend to
do um chat if you have another question
or was that just your hand that's still
up
okay so let me um move on
so why would you um participate in 401k
savings schemes we already talked about
this what are the costs of
non-participation
essentially three main reasons from the
workers perspective
there's foregone tax benefits and the
tax benefits are again your marginal tax
rate
um usually while people are working
tends to be higher than the marginal tax
rate when people are retiring
so essentially by um uh investing in
401k
savings they can defer taxes
um and that's uh save some taxes second
um people uh uh forego
the employer match i'll tell you about
this in a second
and number three is um that's a little
more subtle which is um foregone
consumption smoothing
which essentially is like your marginal
um
uh the marginal value of a dollar for
you um
while you're working at age 30 or 40
tends to be lower than the marginal
value of a dollar once you're 70 or 80.
the reason being that essentially you're
richer you have more money available
when you're 30 or 40.
so you actually want to smooth
consumption until later in time of
course there's a discounting
motive going the other way but it
shouldn't be that essentially at age 59
or
64 you earn a lot of money and consume a
lot and then the year after
um once you retire your consumption
drops a lot
um economists would say you should
smooth this out by
essentially saving some money to the
future and then 401k sailing scenes
might help you with that
now why do companies care um already
said that essentially oh
sorry come back there's a
non-highly compensated employees don't
save an alpha don't say very much in
particular nd schemes
and the irs non-discrimination tests has
essentially non-discrimination tests
in pension plans that precisely um
try to prevent that so really what you
want to do is you want to get your
low-income workers to
save more okay so now uh here comes the
paper by madrid and chair that's a very
um
successful one of the most successful
papers in behavioral economics
the reason being that um uh a
you know standard economics has sort of
failed in some ways in the sense of
saying like
we tried um matching contributions we
tried giving people education or
information and so on and so forth
and none of these things have worked
very well
and then instead something that
shouldn't matter which is what i'm going
to show you in a second the defaults
mattered a lot and had huge effects and
which is very hard for standard
economics to explain
and then on top of that this is in a
domain where we really care about a lot
savings is one of the most important
choices that economists have
considered and so that's a very good
example of like
an early example of an aspect of
behavioral economics in this case
default
that really matters in some ways that's
hard to explain
for standard economics and that is
standard tools of economics seem to not
have been working
very well okay so what does the paper
actually do it it's it's a large
publicly
traded fortune 500 healthcare company
you can enroll in 401k savings plans any
day by essentially filling out an
enrollment form or calling the 401k
record keeper what does that mean
essentially you you
call somebody and say i want you to
invest in 401k savings when you're in
this company
and you're gonna say i'm gonna uh
uh you know i want to say say five
percent of my earnings
i want to save every month uh or you
could fill out a form
now these days a lot of this is like
online so if at mit you want to change
your forwarding key savings
you essentially have to like fill out an
online form and change your online
allocation potentially so there's
potentially like a small
transaction costs um involved but notice
that the transaction cost tends to be
very minor in a sense like it's gonna
take you maybe like 10 minutes maybe
like 20 minutes maybe if you think about
it for a while it takes you an hour
but really it's like a very minor
cost of time overall that should that
just cost you
uh compared to the potentially huge
benefits of
uh employer matches and so on now what
are these employer matches
in this particular company it's a 50
matching contribution
for the first six percent so again what
are these percentages
the percentages are um essentially the
fraction of your income that you're
you'd like to contribute to these
savings for example
five percent or three percent or seven
percent
is what you're saving and now the
company says they're going to match a 50
uh for the first six percent for example
if an
uh employee chooses four percent the
company pays an additional two percent
into that um uh savings account right
away
right so that's actually quite a bit of
money if an employee chooses uh 10
the the company pays an additional three
percent because you know that
employee has above the cap of six
percent so you net
cannot get more than three percent uh
from the company
um other companies these days have even
like a hundred percent matching
contribution
uh for the fives for five percent of the
like that tends to be fairly um
common so for example mit has like 100
matching
uh contribution for the first i think uh
five percent
um in the specific company the employees
are first eligible after one year of
employment before the change
happened of the policy then we're going
to talk about it in a second now notice
that this is
like a terrible policy uh from a
behavioral economics
perspective in terms of like if you
wanted people to sign up and really do
this
that's not what you would do if i'm
telling you like here's the thing that i
want you to sign up for
in a year from now please come back and
do it well
you know in a year from now people might
forget people might procrastinate
people might sort of like you know be
busy with other things
so it's you know it's not um a policy
that's
great to do to start with to get people
involved in some sense there's no wonder
that
participation early on was kind of like
low
now the company does that because
turnover tends to be high and you kind
of try to avoid paying people early on
uh that might leave anyway and you have
to deal with the paperwork and so on and
so forth
notice that that might be exactly the
wrong thing to do because once people
have
paid into their 401k savings maybe that
creates some loyalty and makes
workers to stay more at the company
anyway but for what it's worth in this
particular case
uh employers were only eligible one year
after employment
now then there's a discontinuity of the
401k
plan default based on the date of fire
so here's the old court
the window court as i call it the new
court um
so the old court that people are hired
between
1st of april 96 and 31st of
march 97. essentially people have been
previously hired
this is what i just told you um you can
after one year after hire after being
hired after one year
you can uh you're not automatically
enrolled but you can essentially just
call somebody and say
i would like to start saving in my 401k
savings or you could fill out this form
then there's the new court which
essentially is automatic enrollment
which is everything is exactly the same
but by the date of hire so when you're
hired immediately
um you're automatically enrolled so
they're not they're they're not asking
you
they're giving you some information but
they say unless you change unless you
want to make a change you're going to be
automatically involved
immediately and when you automatically
involve somebody
then you need to also specify where the
money goes to so they have an automatic
enrollment
you need to choose the contribution rate
which is the default contribution rate
and they need to have the default
fund allocation which is so the default
contribution rate which is three percent
and you need to put the money somewhere
right so if i'm automatically
doing something for you with your money
i need to put the money somewhere
what the company is doing is the company
puts the money into the money market
um fund uh is that
a good idea a bad idea why is the
company putting the money into the money
market fund is that what you're supposed
to be doing with your savings or what
or maybe first explain what is the money
market fund and then tell what is it a
good a bad idea somebody says they saw
the dot-com
bubble coming potentially but i think if
you were
saved for retirement what should you do
give some free investment advice
for everybody what should you do what
are people telling you like if you go to
somebody who does finance
but essentially what people would argue
you should be doing is uh
you should invest in stocks or some
forms of um
a diversified diversified portfolio of
stocks you should buy essentially the
stock market the s p 500 or
the world stock market or the like which
essentially is
risky but also has a much higher return
now
uh given that like if you start
investing at age like you know 25 or 30
if you do that for 30 40 years that has
a very
likely very high long-run return and a
much higher long
return that you will have if you invest
in the money market
now there's a question of like what is
the optimal uh risk and so on
but investing every nobody no investment
uh advisor in their right mind maybe
perhaps partially because they want to
make money but i think only
including people who wants the best for
you will tell you you should invest
everything in the money market
now why are the companies doing that and
essentially the company is worried about
liability and about getting sued or
getting at least like in trouble with
their
employees now if they default so
essentially if i'm
if i'm not offering any uh retirement
savings then i'm like of course that's
not a big risk to take if i'm instead
signing i'm hiring you and i'm putting
your money without really getting
explicit consent for you without you
explicitly saying you want it
i'm putting your money into some
investment fund
and potentially a risky investment fund
and that thing like essentially crashes
and people lose a lot of money they're
going to get really upset with you
potentially
and that's for the from the company's
perspective just not worth doing
essentially the company wants to help
people again remember
a part of the motive of the company was
just to get people to contribute in the
first place
to essentially get around their rs
non-discrimination roles
and so the company is really not
necessarily that interested in high
returns for
um for their workers and in particular
companies worried potentially about like
essentially the stock market crashing
and then sort of people getting really
upset with them which would be quite
costly um for them and then they would
be like why did you put the money in
this risky thing
while in fact you know uh you could have
put it in the money market and so on
and the reason being is essentially
because there is no explicit consent
because it's essentially a default
option where i'm essentially
the default is such that like you're
automatically enrolled
so unless you tell me otherwise you're
gonna be the money's gonna put there
and you know um so there's never
something where the person says yes i
want the money to be invested in x or
um why okay so then
this here is the main result of the
paper which is the participation rates
in 401k
savings accounts are dramatically higher
with automatic
enrollment compared to the previous
regime so you see here
this is the old cohort this is the
window court um and these are like
previous courts
so you see that prior to automatic
enrollment the participation
increases uh or increased with tenure
that is to say the longer you're at the
company
the higher the fraction of people who
participate in 401k
savings but even people have been in the
company for 20 plus years
have a company have only like a
contribution rate of about 83
um now if you do automatic enrollment
which is uh
you know getting people enrolled but
like
people are free to choose whatever they
want if they don't want to invest money
into the 401k savings account they can
opt out at any point in time
but when you do that people get
essentially way more likely to be
enrolled the participation rate is as
high as 86
so there's essentially dramatic
differences in what you would argue is
like a very important choice which is
you know if you think about like what
are important choices in your life
savings choice is one of the most
important ones so there's dramatic
differences and when you do automatic
enrollment people are way more likely to
enroll
and then if not now in addition
uh sorry uh and then this is here is i
guess sort of the
the part about the uh low-income workers
when you look at
um this is when you look at the first
two columns of this table
uh here you see um these effects um
so first you see this is the window
cohort here this is the chord that was
essentially before the
change was done and here is the um
the new chord which is uh the chord that
receives automatic enrollment
the difference is dramatic from like 37
to 86 um
and this is now by compensation levels
of workers
and what you see here is in the window
chord you see this huge gradient here
um by compensation so workers who are
this is before the automatic enrollment
workers who received um
fewer than twenty thousand dollars um
per year
only twelve point five percent of them
actually could uh uh we're participating
in 401k savings to start with
and among people who earned a lot
already anyway was uh this thing was
like 68 percent
there's a huge discrepancy here and this
is precisely where the irs
the the irs um discrimination rules for
guiding
now um but if you look at like after the
enrollment there's still notice that
there's still some gradient
right there's still essentially like a
higher uh participation rate
among the high paid employers but the
rating is much flatter
because essentially so many among the
low income workers or low
wage workers uh are now enrolled as well
so this huge effect and the effect is
disproportionately large
among low-income workers um what are
potential reasons for that
so they have more likely they're
essentially that credit constraints are
more likely to bind or they have a high
marginal utility of money
and therefore there might be less
inclined to save notice that low-income
workers also
have a high margin utility of income
like in the future
so in some ways it's not obvious
actually that like when you think about
sort of if you write down a model
you think about like should you save
right now versus um uh
consume money so consume versus save
um you will get essentially what this
what this depends on is your marginal
the ratio of your marginal utility right
now versus in the future
and the marginal utility of poor workers
in the future will also be high
so it's not obvious that they shouldn't
be saving but i think it's right that
you're saying they have more emergencies
and more reasons to essentially not want
the money um
um right now so one thing would be just
it's like mechanical and a sense of like
you know in some ways it could just be
that for whatever reason the poor are
not
um saving to start with maybe that's in
part due to like tenure maybe it's due
to like some other reasons that
uh we don't quite understand um
but it might also be that they're sort
of the uh
the poor might be more prone to default
effects
which could be in part with what carmen
was saying they're sort of
in a way uh perhaps financial
sophistication or education
or information just what's the right
thing to do might be lower
and you might just say like i don't
understand what's going on so i'm just
doing what the company does from the end
or so for the best and then you know you
might just sort of
go whatever that is and you're less
confident in making different
uh or over hiding such choices um
another explanation and i'm going to
talk about this when we talk about
poverty a bit which is the idea that
poverty taxes people's bandwidth and
attention that's the same like
essentially being poor
is really hard in various ways you have
to struggle with so many different
things about paying your bills and so on
and so forth which is precisely kind of
what
jose emile was saying in part uh uh
your marginal utility of money might be
high and you will be concerned with that
and you
worried about like feeding your children
and so on and so forth
and it's just really hard to find a time
to think about stuff carefully
and therefore you might again sort of
just go with the default because you
just
don't have the bandwidth the mental
bandwidth to think about like what's
best for you and override
that so that's an open question in fact
whether
um the poor are more likely to be prone
to to default effects
but i think what's what's uh uh almost
surely
the case or what's what's been shown in
their studies is that these effects tend
to have
larger effects among poor or low
compensation workers
which is precisely one of the reasons
why they were so popular um
overall okay so then in addition
um not only are there large effects on
the
contribution decision overall it's like
do you want to participate or the
participation decision overall
you want to participate versus not like
you want to
contribute any money versus not but also
there seem to be large effects on the
contribution rate that is to say um i
think i
told you or remember i told you the
contribution the default contribution
rate was three percent
so if you were automatically enrolled
the company would just give you a three
percent contribution
uh uh standard you could change that to
four percent two percent seven percent
whatever you want to do
but the default would be um three
percent and you see essentially the
majority of people
the fraction of employees in the new uh
court which is the auto
automatic enrollment chooses uh three
percent
there's another thing that's quite
interesting here what you see is that
among people um who arguably would have
chosen
uh just look at the window court there's
some people like for example who chose
six percent eleven percent of people in
the
in the window court is the court that
was just before the
automatic involvement 11 of people chose
um six percent that
fraction actually goes down to seven
percent that is to say
some people who would have chosen more
than three percent uh
in the absence of automatic enrollment
now they're moving down to three percent
so there's some effect there's a bunch
of mass coming from zero percent moving
to three percent
but there's also some mass coming from
here that moves from essentially
positive amounts
down to three percent so there's a very
heterogeneous effect
some people quite a few people increase
their savings from very low rates or
zero rates to three percent
but there's also some other effect that
essentially some people who would have
like
sat down and done the choice themselves
they would have probably
chosen something like a six percent
seven whatever eight even like fifteen
percent
uh and some of them are moved down to
three percent by the automatic
enrollment
so there's some negative effect on
savings coming from that
potentially in addition the
asset allocation
here people essentially predominantly
just you choose the default uh here you
see essentially
the assets or stocks bonds in money
market
think about money market essentially is
like a zero percent or close to zero
percent uh very safe
uh option and
in the new court 80 of people i'm not
sure
how well you can see this but 80 of
people choose the money market which
essentially is exactly what the company
is choosing um
for them well if you have uh
in the other cohorts this is an all
conditional and participating
the frac who chooses um stocks
and bonds is way way higher and as we
discussed
the long long run return to investing in
the
money market is way way lower so that's
potentially like um
again another reason why in fact while
defaults are
increasing the fraction of people who
are choosing to save overall or to
participate in the savings overall
the long-term savings might not
necessarily be um
higher now let me sort of summarize this
i think i said i read already
most of this so uh 40 to 50 of
individuals are passive savers as you
might want to call them they follow the
default plan
essentially both in terms of the
participation but also in the
contribution rate
and the asset allocation they
essentially do whatever the company
chooses for them the suggestive choice
is not very
attractive unless it's the default
notice remember the window chord the
window chord was essentially the chord
that now
could just do whatever they wanted to do
they were
told on the first of april i think 97 or
8. now you can um invest immediately you
can do whatever you want we're not
choosing for you but you are like now
eligible even for people who have been
like at the company for something like
say six months or three months and so on
the company just made
the participation available for anybody
since they had been hired previously
they didn't default people in
they just made it like you can change
your choice now if you want it but among
those people
the window court is very much looking
like the old court they're not sort of
following the company
station you might say well the company
has a new default now and the new
default
um that's the recommendation so i should
just follow that default because i don't
know what to do
that's not what people seem to do so
it's not like that so that doesn't seem
to be that
the default is like a perceived uh
choice that
suggests company and because the window
chord really does not follow this uh
default uh or the suggested default the
window chord really looks like the old
uh now i only showed you the results for
one company from madrid and share but
it's a very robust result that
if you look at like the people by
schweitel that looks at this uh
uh in more detail that finds this over
and over again in different companies as
well
default effects tend to be very strong
in those companies
now one question you might ask is what's
explaining what's the underlying reason
why these default effects are
so strong there are potential candidates
which are awareness
implicit endorsement by the company in
attention
um or potentially um present bias and
what researchers found
um it's sort of not necessarily
conclusive but i think the suggestive
evidence here is very much that
in particular from blumenstock at all
that we think that um
present bias might be a quite important
reason
um uh in addition to sort of the
cognitive costs of
thinking through different savings
scenarios so people essentially tend to
push the staff and say oh i'm going to
change in the future
i'll like you know at some point i'll
get to it i'll get to it when
it's important notice that it needs to
require some naivete because
as we discussed if you're sophisticated
you might sort of
push it off maybe a period or two but
you would never push it off by ten years
or five years because you know you're
going to lose a lot of money
and so um but you know if you have some
present bias plus something
you might say well i'm going to do it in
the future
and not right now and um
that seems to fit the data the best in
part because
papers such as the one by bloom and
stock and all have ruled out some other
explanation
for example the inattention memory
stories they sent reminders that didn't
seem to have any effects
they also could rule out the implicit
endorsement because they essentially
explicitly randomized whether people
were defaulted in versus defaulted out
that also had effects so it doesn't seem
to be that they also will make people
very clearly aware of the different
retirements or savings options
and again that didn't seem to make a a
big effect so what
why we don't have like conclusive
evidence that present bias is
is sort of causing these default effects
in the retirement savings choice scheme
perhaps if i had to guess or if i had to
say which i think is the most likely
explanation you think that present bias
and idk
seem to be um
the best explanations that we have on so
far
so now one question you might sort of
say is well um
is automatic enrollment uh optimal i
showed you essentially that once we do
automatic enrollment people are more
likely to participate
however while they're more likely to
participate
also these defaults
seem to make some people save less right
we saw some people going essentially
from six percent participation uh
contribution rate to three percent
contribution rate they also
are um have a much more conservative
asset allocation
so in the long run it's not obvious in
the case of uh
this company whether people are actually
saving uh uh
more so how how would we answer this
question we're gonna get back to this
when we talk about policy
but how should we uh how should we set
the default what should we do
like what are the considerations that we
have and how can we decide what's good
for people
you can essentially um force people to
make a choices there were some companies
where essentially people were
very very strongly encouraged to
essentially here's a form fill it out
tell me what you want
and it was sort of part of the hiring
package and you know like essentially
was sort of arguing i don't think that's
actually legal but it was essentially
sort of implying that like
one needs to do this form before you can
start working and otherwise you know you
can't start working at this company
and now we can look at like what are
people actually choosing when everybody
chooses
actively and that's presumably when
people are paying attention or when
people do the best they can for their
choices
and they're not sort of automatically
enrolled either in zero or three or
other percentages
and so this company this paper by
carolina looks at active choices
and when people choose actively they
look a lot like the new chord in madrid
and share
so essentially that sort of seems to say
that the default um
uh did in fact default into like
automatic enrollment
uh seem to have alleviated under savings
right so because you know when people
choose actively that choose a lot look a
lot like the new chord compared to the
old chord so it seems to be that like
people when they're defaulted in the no
savings option they kind of maybe think
oh
you know i'll do it in the future and so
on and so forth but then they never sort
of get to it
um now when you actually ask them
actively what you want it seems like
people are mostly
wanting to to enroll now one thing that
is quite interesting here is that uh it
seems like the default
effects seem to mostly disappear after
three years that's true for
quite a few studies um however even if
that's the case where there's no catch
up in levels
right so if you start contributing in
like after three years
while you miss out on three years of
savings you're never going to catch up
overall
moreover people tend to change their
employers
um very frequently in particular in the
us
so if you only if it takes you only if
it takes you three years to like sign up
for retirement savings every time
you switch to your employer you know
you're going to not save um
very much uh teddy and i'll have an
example where they find in fact very
clear effects on long run savings of
these types of default
effects now let me tell you um a little
bit now about our
i'm going to sort of move the frames and
nudges until next time which i think
should be fine because there's not that
much
left anyway but let me tell you a little
bit about sort of a cost generation
about um
defaults this is a paper by a very short
paper by cronkrist and uh
thaler that looks at the privatization
of social security and sweden
so they had 456 funds and there was one
default fund
chosen by the government and in 2000
this default fund was discouraged with a
massive marketing campaign essentially
people said like don't choose the
default fund
just pick for yourself make the choice
that's the best for you
and then in 2003 this marketing campaign
ended and now essentially
the majority again sort of chose the um
default
account fun now as it happens
uh uh you know the portfolio is actively
chosen in 2000 um
or did a lot worse than the default so
people essentially
[Music]
were choosing on their own and in part i
think because they're just unlucky
because it happened to be at the wrong
time in the wrong place
um chose sort of very risky assets and
the default tended to be somewhat more
conservative
so people lost a lot of money
so now that's the more general issue is
that active choice is less attractive if
consumers
are less financially sophisticated again
in the cronkite state like case maybe
they were just unlucky but in general
if you want people to choose actively
and they don't know what they're doing
well then you know they're going to be
potentially
um worse there's similar evidence for
example for health insurance choices
where people just don't know what health
insurance choice is best
for them so if you give them more
options
they might be potentially doing worse
because they just don't know what to do
and then they choose just options that
are worse and they're more likely for
example to be
exploited and then having a default
choice that
is perhaps not optimal for everybody but
it's pretty conservative and pretty good
for most people
might be in fact um quite valuable and
so now when you think about like
um uh optimal uh decision regimes
when you think about active choice
versus default consumer
um heterogeneity makes active choice
more um attractive if
you think you know people want all
people want very different things and
you know
um they know about what's best for them
and they and we don't have that
information we don't know what's good
for some people versus others
well it's best to let people choose on
their own right let's just pick what's
good for them
and you know then they'll be um happy
but active choice only improves outcome
if people actually know what's good for
them if everybody's confused and doesn't
know what they're doing
well then you know letting people choose
actively um will potentially make things
worse for quite a few
um people and so you want to make sure
that defaults don't make people
worse this is what jodae was saying in
particular people might sort of hope for
a save if you like default them into
high savings and then they have credit
card debt or other sort of problems
arising from that so it wants to be
quite careful
one option one can try and do is trying
to provide information sessions and make
sure people know
here's like where try to sort of provide
a curated set of like three four options
that we think are good options for
different types of people provide
information for them make sure they
understand
um uh these options and that then people
choose um
on their own another popular alternative
i'm going to talk about this a little
bit and we talk about policy
which is called the smart plan or like
auto escalation plans
which are essentially more like
automatic raises in the future
where you um
where you essentially can commit to
automatically raising your
savings in the future you say
essentially every time i get a pay raise
one percent or like some fraction of
that pay raise or one percentage point
of my earnings of that pay raise
will go through like um my savings
so then you know uh uh uh you don't have
to like essentially reduce your
consumption or your salary right now
that you receive
but in the future that's good ginseng in
particular addresses addresses present
bias and loss aversion because people
are really averse to like
reducing their paycheck right now and
for present bias and loss of version
when i was asking about like information
versus financial education
i mean kind of both of those you can
provide information about like what are
these options
you know what's good about this this
investment option versus another
and so providing financial education but
in particular
financial education plus active choice
previously by essentially by active
choice i mean like pushing people really
to choose and saying like look
what do you want you want option a which
is like no
retirement savings or option b which is
like three percent or six percent or
whatever
the current format is more um
essentially is like
no information and the default is
essentially is like
zero savings and then you have to
accurately choose on your own as an
employer and many employee employees so
as an employee
many employees just don't know what to
do and get confused and then you get
frazzled and procrastinated and never do
it
perhaps in part because of confusion um
okay
and then you know other settings have
like enormous before the fact this is
for example true for organ donations i
talked about this already in the uh
first or second lecture um there's some
other um
settings such as uh voter registration
uh green energy options and so on
so default effects can be um really
really powerful
um but one wants to be quite careful in
using them i'm going to talk about this
a little bit
um uh at the end of this lecture um next
time let me stop here let me just tell
you
um uh let me just tell you what to read
um
which is one second
which is uh uh uh the people are early
at all um
sections one through four you can read
more if you want but like um
uh section one one through four already
gets you pretty far
this is really like a fun paper um that
questions a lot of assumptions of
neoclassical economics
uh you know makes you wonder kind of
where preferences come from
and uh what they really mean uh so it's
a fun read um
i'll talk about this uh and the
remaining part of um this lecture which
is a bit on frames and
nudges more generally next time on
wednesday
let me know if you have any questions
thank you so much